SCP-1730 is one of the biggest threats the
Foundation has ever faced.
SCP-1730 does not exist.
It was June 5th when the compound was first
discovered.
A large complex of structures in rural Texas,
about fifteen kilometers northwest of the
Mexican border.
Located in Big Bend Ranch State Park, it was
easily the biggest structure in the area.
But there was no record of any such structure
ever being built.
A massive network of power stations, containment
facilities, and research buildings, SCP-1730
looked like it had been abandoned for a long
time.
The exterior was degraded, but the building
was still operating.
A power generator had been running for an
indeterminate amount of time, even as the
infrastructure degraded.
Power flickered through the sight and fuel
leaked frequently.
But there was one detail that attracted the
attention of SCP brass.
SCP-1730 bore identifying markings linking
it to Foundation Site 13, a research facility
that was marked for construction near Nome,
Alaska.
But Site 13 had never been built, having been
abandoned in the planning stages.
So why is it in the middle of Texas, fully
constructed and long abandoned?
The Foundation needed to know more, and they
needed their best to investigate.
It was time to call in the “Game Wardens”.
Apollo-3, the mobile task force used to investigate
dangerous sites, was brought in, and five
elite agents were briefed and sent in - Ross,
Houston, Noah, Ohalo, and Vigo.
It didn’t take long for them to discover
that something was very wrong with the site
of SCP-1730.
The facility was located in the middle of
south Texas - but the local flora surrounding
it was native to Nome, Alaska.
Something had transplanted a building that
shouldn’t exist to another place and time.
Commander Ross ordered his men to enter, with
Houston taking lead, and they discovered that
entry led down a long staircase.
They descended slowly, following a strange
light that no one could identify - but had
a sudden shock when they discovered that the
basement of the staircase was missing.
The light suddenly stopped, and it became
so dark that it was impossible to see what
lay beyond the staircase.
Upon probing the inky black void at the base
of the staircase, they determined it wasn’t
a fog or shadow.
It was a liquid.
And it was rising.
Ross ordered his men back, but Houston was
in too deep.
He couldn’t break free from the inky black
liquid.
The men pulled him away, and got him free
- but his legs were gone!
Not ripped off, because there was no blood
anywhere.
Smoothly cut off, as if they were never there.
And as they put Houston down, he stood up
- on phantom legs.
He didn’t feel any pain, but everyone could
tell something was very wrong with this place.
And the messages they started seeing on the
wall made clear they weren’t the only ones
who knew it.
“What Happened to Site 13?”
“Death Here”
“Not My Body”
“Bleed”
There had been other people - or things - inside
SCP-1730, and they wanted anyone who entered
to know that this was a very dangerous place
to be.
As they advanced down the hall back towards
the entrance, they saw what looked like a
person in the distance.
But as they approached, it became clear this
wasn’t another explorer.
It was an old, horribly disfigured corpse
seemingly attached to the wall.
Not by chains - but fused into the wall in
unnatural ways.
At first, the team seemed unconcerned - recognizing
the corpse as someone named Zachary.
Fortunately, command back at base realized
this as the effects of some sort of cognitohazard
- a mental infection - in the base.
They uploaded a filter to their helmets, and
the team recoiled in horror at the site in
front of them.
But the horrors were just beginning.
They turned around to see a shimmering, humanoid
entity in the hallway behind them.
As it approached, its footsteps distorted
the hallway around.
It pulled AP-3 Noah towards it, without touching
him, and as the soldier was pulled into its
clutches, his body started to distort.
Vigo was next, being grabbed by the arm by
a long appendage, and his arm started to change
color and distort.
But the foundation sent Apollo-3 in prepared.
Houston produced a portable reality anchor,
designed to handle reality-warping entities,
and with a flash of red light the creature
was revealed.
It was a horribly elongated humanoid that
only existed for a second before the reality
anchor erased it and restored the hallway
to its normal state.
Vigo would recover, with the strange red color
in his arm fading eventually.
Noah wasn’t so lucky.
He was already dead.
And had been fused into the wall just like
the unfortunate corpse.
These horrors had been encountered just by
trying to return to the entrance, so it was
clear the only smart thing to do was to descend
further into the facilities and get some answers.
As they advanced, not encountering any other
supernatural entities, they saw more evidence
of the dark things that had occurred in Site
13.
The infirmary had been torn apart, a cafeteria
had been melted into slag, and a large group
of containment cells ended with a section
called “Olympia Class”.
But while most of the other cells were standard
sized, these were over 100 meters high.
What had the foundation - or whoever ran this
place - been keeping in these cells?
They would get more answers as they made their
way down another hall, where they saw a single
television still working and illuminating
their hallway.
At first the television flickered, but the
image soon cleared, and the agents were able
to see what was broadcasting.
It was the interior of a containment cell.
And there was someone in it.
And they recognized them as one of the most
dangerous beings contained by the SCP Foundation
- Bobble the Clown.
A predatory supernatural clown that inhabits
a children’s TV show, Bobble the Clown was
broadcast by an unknown source and could only
be seen by children under ten.
Originally seeming to be a normal kids’
show about a clown, every episode eventually
devolved into the murderous Bobble teaching
the kids how to do horrible things like arson
or torture.
The Foundation eventually captured and isolated
Bobble’s broadcast, but the clown remained
hostile and vicious.
Not here.
As the team talked to the Bobble trapped in
the mysterious Site 13, it became clear that
this clown was broken by whatever it had experienced.
It rambled, it hid from the camera, and it
was clearly terrified as it told the team
about the horrors of the site.
And it seemed to recognize the agents as something
familiar - but not completely familiar.
It claimed to be able to smell them - and
said they smelled different.
As Bobble rambled on and on, the agents learned
about a man named Emerson, who ran the site.
Like the Foundation, he was obsessed with
containing the strange and dangerous entities
in the world.
But unlike the foundation, he didn’t just
want to protect the world from them.
He hated them.
The entities in Site 13 didn’t even have
numbers - they might identify by them.
Emerson wanted to use them up however he wanted
and dispose of them - in something Bobble
called the “meat grinder”.
Entities that outlived their usefulness were
taken down below - and none were ever heard
from again.
It was directly counter to every SCP Foundation
policy - but this site had clearly been performing
these horrible experiments for years.
How?
And why hadn’t anyone ever heard of it?
The team continued to make their way into
the facility, but their signals were lost
as they entered the cryogenics unit.
By the time contact had been restored, they
were no longer alone.
There were survivors.
Both agents of the foundation - and survivors
of the facility.
And they were angry.
With no way out and massively outnumbered,
they called for backup.
Mobile Task Force T-5, also known as “Samsara”,
was reserved for the heavy-duty missions.
They’re an elite group of practically immortal
cyborgs fashioned from the flesh of a god,
and equipped with further cybernetic enhancements
to eliminate Keter-level threats and to protect
themselves from cognitohazards.
They were sent in through a drainage gate
to look for survivors and neutralize whatever
lay within.
They didn’t know what to expect, but they
knew one thing - no one who had been sent
in had come out.
It wasn’t long before they realized how
dangerous this mission would be.
As they came across some large gated drainage
pipes, they could see at least twenty charred
bodies of humanoids pushed up against the
gate, some reaching their hands through.
Whatever had happened in Site 13, these unfortunate
beings had been desperate to escape.
As they made their way down the drainage pipe,
they could feel it getting hotter, as if they
were nearing an energy source.
And there was one other odd thing about the
pipe.
It was draining inward, not out.
They made their way to a control room, where
many of the consoles had been destroyed.
Looking through a window, their view was obscured
by a mysterious black mass.
On the control panels, they could read terms
like “incinerator” and “body pit access”.
They split up, trying to find answers, but
found many of their accesses blocked by the
black mass.
As the T-5 task force argued over their next
move, they were startled by a sudden jolt.
The giant mass had started moving.
The team watched as the mass spun, revealing
a giant turbine, which turned the inky substance
into a fine slurry that was then scorched
by giant streaks of fire.
One of T-5 shot open the glass chamber, allowing
the team to get closer - and blasting them
with a wave of heat.
As they descended into the chamber, they could
see a massive plant-like structure overhead,
which started to shake.
Suddenly, thousands of glowing pods were released
from the massive plant, and each one lit up
and let the team view the chamber more clearly.
But it was what was inside the pods that was
more disturbing.
Each pod had a humanoid shape inside, seemingly
reaching towards the team, until they hit
the slurry below - and the shadows went dark.
The team descended to investigate the slurry,
when something started to leak out of the
walls.
Looking at it, they could see something moving
within.
One of the team members picked the wriggling
object out of the black liquid - and it took
a bite out of his hand!
It was a leech - and there were thousands
more of them moving towards the slurry, consuming
it.
And as the leeches ate, they started growing.
They seemed to be moving in unison, communicating
with a larger being lurking at the base of
the slurry.
A larger leech, a queen?
Or something else?
The team wasn’t sticking around to find
out.
They beat a hurried escape from the leech
room, finding themselves in another hallway.
Whatever the black substance was, the entities
who had been here had used it, scrawling “Blood”
on the walls over and over again.
Occasionally, they would come across a drained
corpse covered in the black fluid.
Had the leeches bled them dry?
The facility was so sprawling that the team
knew that if they wanted any chance of navigating
it safely, they needed to get the lay of the
land.
They needed to find the control center.
The door read “Stairs to Cryonics” and
the leeches were nowhere to be found.
It seemed like a safe path.
But as soon as the team entered, the temperature
dropped drastically, to well below where it
would be safe for a human to survive.
The team’s internal heating system kicked
in, saving their lives, but that wasn’t
the only threat.
The team was about to encounter exactly what
Site 13 was keeping locked up.
As soon as they entered the room, sound ceased
to work.
The filters in their gear were overloaded,
and the team saw warnings around the room.
“Silence”
“Don’t Look”
A massive, multi-limbed figure emerged, with
each of its sixty arms moving independently.
The creature had no head, but a large circular
structure covered with ancient glowing symbols.
Whatever it was, it was ancient, all-powerful
- and deadly.
The team scrambled to get away, as the glyphs
on the creature burned white hot.
Anyone who touched it was burned.
Anyone who looked too long at it felt their
optical implants burn out.
The symbols on the creature were indecipherable,
but one word was clear and printed in English.
“EMERSON”
Site 13 was from another world, another timeline
where the SCP foundation evolved into something
horrible.
Ruled over by Elliott Emerson, it tortured
its captured beings, and eventually killed
most of them in the horrors of the incinerators.
When an escape threatened to destroy the facility,
Emerson successfully activated a device that
removed the facility from their world - into
ours.
Of course, as any avid follower of the SCP
Foundation will know, there’s far more to
the story than this.
Emerson may have been the start of Site 13’s
problems, but he was far from the end.
It’s the mission of the century.
A daring rescue into the depths of one of
the most dangerous locations in the multiverse:
Site 13, otherwise known as SCP – 1730.When
the impossible Site 13 was first discovered,
multiple Mobile Task Forces were sent to plumb
its depths and none returned.
They were greeted to a labyrinthine nightmare,
littered with deadly cognitohazards, escaped
SCPs, and mysterious, murderous leeches.
Some were trapped, along with the civilians
they were sent to rescue.
Others were killed or changed in unimaginable
ways.
Mobile Task Force Apollo-3, also known as
“The Game Wardens”, had been sent in on
a rescue mission when they encountered a horrifying
sight: The captured broadcast of Bobble The
Clown, a dangerous SCP known for corrupting
and destroying children through its deadly
messages.
But this Bobble was different.
Much like everything from Site 13, this Bobble
came from an entirely different dimension,
and he had terrifying information to relay:
In the universe where Site 13 originated,
the site’s psychopathic director, one Elliot
Emerson, had struck a deal with the Global
Occult Coalition – a controversial government
group who intends to “protect” humanity
by killing anomalies rather than containing
them.
Emerson had converted his site into an unethical,
unrestrained slaughterhouse, and was incinerating
SCPs by the hundred in a so-called Body Pit.
But Emerson’s game of death came back and
bit him, snapping the threads of reality and
turning the entire site into a dimensionally
displaced super-anomaly.
The Game Wardens realized they were in way
over their heads.
Their chances of surviving this place were
dropping by the second, and if they wanted
any chance of succeeding in their mission,
they needed backup, so Site Command called
in MTF Tau-5, aka “Samsara.”
Calling in Samsara for a run-of-the-mill collection
mission is like using a bazooka to kill a
housefly, but for a case as severe as 1730,
their skills were not only nice to have but
vital.
Samsara are among the best of the best: Immortal
cybernetic clones forged from the flesh of
a god, equipped with weaponry and technology
that could surpass even that of other elite
Mobile Task Force units.
The four members of Samsara are so adept at
what they do that they earned the nickname
“Power Rangers” among their peers.
The remaining Game Wardens knew that with
Samsara on the case, they may actually survive
this thing after all, they just needed to
hold out.
Samsara arrived on site not long after, packing
some serious technological heat – including
arm-mounted incendiary cannons, shock-absorbing
leg extensions, heat-resistant plating, and
built-in SCRAMBLE adaptations within their
eyes to ward off the deadly cognitohazards.
Everyone involved was in for the fight of
their lives.
The four Samsara agents – Irantu, Nanku,
Munru, and Onru – entered via a drainage
gate in one of the office buildings above
ground and began their descent inside.
After observing numerous charred bodies, they
deduced that there must be a massive incinerator
somewhere on site.
Emerson’s incinerator.
Theorizing this was connected to the “Body
Pit” they kept hearing about, they descended
further, feeling the temperature rise as they
did so.
Due to the anomalous nature of 1730, nothing
inside made any kind of logical sense.
Caused by a reality-warping machine known
as THRESHER, the internal geography of Site
13 was subject to constant shifts.
The team then split up to cover more ground
– Munro and Nanku continued to follow the
pipes and the heat towards the furnace, while
Irantu and Onru broke away to explore what
lay beyond a weak wall.
After busting through the wall, Irantu and
Onru explored several empty office blocks
before finding their way into a control room
with a glass observation deck.
While the window was obscured by garbage and
human corpses, signage indicated that the
incinerator and the body pit were directly
below them.
The team once again reconvened, and managed
to activate the incinerator, which shredded
the mass stuck inside with several large turbines
before burning the resulting slurry, the same
process that had happened to so many anomalies
under Emerson’s watch.
With the path cleared, Samsara decided to
descend via the incinerator, using the drainage
pipe as a kind of makeshift tunnel.
Eventually, they happened upon the leeches.
Large, black, and hungry, these creatures
seemed to infest 1730 by the thousand.
Anywhere that blood or drainage runoff could
be found, the leeches could be found, too.
They didn’t appear to have any connection
to an anomaly previously secured and contained
by the Foundation.
They squeezed and wriggled through the cracks
in the walls, searching for fresh blood.
Onru detected that the leeches all moved with
a kind of collective purpose, suggesting a
telepathic hive mind.
Onru was able to tap into this hive mind using
her cybernetic enhancements, and map the chaotic
geography of 1730 through the leech colony’s
collective knowledge.
With this new advantage, they could add a
second goal to this rescue mission: Find the
THRESHER device causing all the instability,
and potentially reduce power to it if possible.
But they were on the clock to save the other
survivors, as those leeches were sure to get
hungry for warm blood soon.
They followed the leeches down the most direct
path towards the survivors.
On the way, they encountered a horrifying
creature: The many-limbed humanoid nightmare
that functions as Emerson’s eternal punishment,
his charred body tied screaming and alive
to the platform where the monster’s head
should be.
They managed to make it past the monster before
finally rendezvousing with Captain Hollis
of Mobile Task Force Zeta-9, otherwise known
as the “Mole Rats”, as well as the Game
Wardens and the other survivors.
There were 27 surviving members of Site 13
staff, many of which had severe injuries – making
it even harder to transport them back to safety
through hazardous terrain.
And to make matters worse, the leeches were
back.
The team quickly decided that the best route
out of here was directly past the THRESHER,
where they could reduce power to the machine
for just long enough to create a stable path
of escape.
Nanku opened fire on a hoard of approaching
leeches with a flamethrower, and everyone
began running for their lives.
It was a final, make-or-break dash to safety.
However, their advance was soon stopped by
a strange, robed creature drawing a cognitohazardous
meme on the wall with its claws.
When the team attempted to engage, it attacked,
exposing additional deadly memes and the dangerous
effects of its single white eye.
And we’re not talking about internet memes
here.
These are symbols and information that are
often deadly to even bear witness to, and
for you or I, this would be a real threat,
but not to a team equipped with goggles containing
cognitohazard filter technology.
The battle was cut short when the floor collapsed
underneath them and this creature was devoured
by something even larger and more monstrous:
A gigantic black leech covered in huge, red
eyes.
Its entrance caused thousands of leeches to
spill out into the hall, as the monster screeched
and slithered its tentacles after them.
Allow us to introduce you to Elijah, also
known as The Leech Boy, and a pivotal component
of the very existence of SCP – 1730.
He was a boy with the mind of a toddler, but
he had the strange ability to absorb blood
through people’s skin – hence his nickname,
“Leech Boy.”
One of the doctors in Site 13, Dr. Hadley,
took pity on Elijah – after all, he didn’t
choose to be the way he was.
Director Emerson didn’t share Hadley’s
sympathy.
His orders to exterminate all anomalies included
humanoids like Elijah.
When Hadley protested, Emerson had her beaten
within an inch of her life while other dissenters
were shot.
Dr. Hadley, disgusted by the inhumanity of
her superiors, devised the perfect revenge.
She sabotaged the incinerator and the body
pit, allowing a mass containment breach that
flooded the site with deadly anomalies.
Young Elijah ended up consuming the slurry
of the other shredded anomalies, causing him
to mutate into a powerful monster, a behemoth
of a leech who gave birth to and controlled
all others.
It was Hadley’s revenge that caused Emerson
to panic and activate THRESHER, leading to
the rift in reality and the creation of 1730,
and – by extension – all the problems
faced by our heroes today.
Samsara and the others fled Leech Boy and
began taking a different escape route.
However, while en route, they encountered
the dreaded Crystal Butterflies – a dangerous
SCP capable of destroying organic matter with
a mere touch.
Irantu stepped up to bat, roasting the creatures
with his arm-mounted incinerator and taking
extreme damage to his body in the process.
But they didn’t have time to rest.
With the butterflies disposed of, they kept
moving, heading towards the THRESHER.
But not all the SCPs were necessarily working
against them.
Bobble the Clown came in handy at the next
checkpoint, manifesting in the monitor of
an electronic door and opening the way through.
As they continued on their journey, they had
to fight off frequent attacks from leeches,
losing some of the task force members in the
process.
They were also forced to face off against
a number of other anomalies in order to survive
– such as SCP – 2316 manifesting as floating
bodies beneath them, and SCP – 1370, which
used a huge, mechanized body to attack the
team of survivors.
That was all just a warm-up for the true final
battle, though.
The floor shattered beneath them, and out
of an impossibly huge chamber, the monster
that had once been Elijah wriggled free – reaching
for them with huge tentacles and shrieking
from its thousand-toothed maw.
It was at least two hundred meters tall, and
barely reacted to any amount of firepower.
It seemed like they were all doomed, until
Captain Hollis had a truly crazy idea.
With the help of Samsara, she led the bloodthirsty
abomination down through the cryonics center
and into an Olympia-class testing chamber.
There, as the Leech Boy was bearing down on
them, Hollis opened the gates to two adjacent
containment cells, and something beyond incredible
happened.
Two of the most powerful SCPs ever known – the
giant, sword-wielding gate guardian, and the
reality bending cosmic deer, SCP – 2845
– entered the arena.
What followed was one of the most epic showdowns
in the history of the SCP Foundation, as the
Deer and the Gate Guardian went to battle
against the all-devouring Leech.
While the monsters fought, Hollis ordered
her team to get the rest of the survivors
to safety.
She and Munru of the Samsara team remained
behind to prevent any of the anomalies from
escaping as the entire base began sinking
into the ground from the combined forces of
the battle raging around them and the THRESHER’s
continued onslaught on reality.
Even if the survivors escaped, would the anomalous
developments inside Site 13 escape and wreak
havoc on the world at large?
That’s when Hollis received a vision, a
horrific, charred, post-apocalyptic world
roamed by inconceivably powerful entities
and nightmare gods.
It was a vision so horrific that just seeing
it nearly broke her mind.
She knew what she had to do – the only way
she could truly defeat this terrible place
and ensure safety for mankind.
While Leech Boy, the Gate Guardian, and the
Deer continued their battle for the ages,
Hollis ran to THRESHER and forced the machine
into overdrive.
Up above, the remaining members of Samsara,
the Mole Rats, and the Game Wardens escorted
the survivors to safety.
Downstairs, THRESHER emitted a blinding white
light as the system began to overload.
In her final moments, all Hollis could do
was laugh – perhaps it was a laugh of pure
insanity, of a mind broken by the horror she
witnessed.
Or perhaps it was a laugh of victory, knowing
that in spite of the immense powers all around
her, she had won the day.
She had saved not only the survivors and her
teammates, but possibly all of humanity.
And all it cost her was everything.
Outside, the survivors had reached a safe
distance when the entirety of Site 13 imploded
in a final brilliant flash.
When the dust cleared SCP-1730 was gone, all
that was left was an immense crater where
the impossible base should have once been.
Captain Hollis had done it – through overloading
the THRESHER machine, she’d taken this anomaly
out of the world the exact same way it had
entered.
It was torn from its moorings on our earth
and kicked into the infinity of spacetime,
perhaps never to be seen again, along with
everything it contained.
SCP – 1730 was reclassified to “neutralized.”
Of course, the Foundation would have plenty
of other anomalies to pursue soon after, but
the nightmare of Emerson’s Site 13 was over
once and for all.
A light shines above a metal table, with a
chair positioned on either side.
This is the isolated, hermetically-sealed
interview chamber of Provisional Site 23.
Outside the room waits two shell-shocked human
Mobile Task Force members, another with invisible
ghost legs, three powerful cyborgs, and a
scientist from another dimension.
They’re all here to talk about one thing:
The nightmare that unfolded at Site 13, also
known as SCP - 1730.
Everyone thinks they know the story: A mysterious
site suddenly appears in Texas, seeming to
exactly match the blueprint for an abandoned
site that’s supposed to be in Nome, Alaska.
What started as a simple anomalous location
turned out to be an epic horror from another
dimension.
The task forces sent in by the Foundation
were either massacred or trapped inside, and
those who survived reported seeing unspeakable
carnage inside the base including a death
machine designed to destroy anomalies.
And that’s not all - as a result of the
mysterious Thresher machine, the entire location
had been transformed into a shifting, spatial
anomaly filled with creatures straight out
of a nightmare - from giant, telepathic leech
monsters, to huge, multi-limbed Demi Gods
that would eternally punish the site’s murderous
director, Elliot Emerson.
It was only through the combined might of
three different Mobile Task Forces - including
the legendary Samsara - and the sacrifice
of brave Captain Hollis that this cursed location
was finally flung into a different dimension,
neutralizing the threat it posed to our reality.
But for the SCP Foundation, the story doesn’t
end with neutralization - there’s still
plenty more questions that need answering.
That’s why, today, we’re going to tell
you what they found out after the neutralization
of SCP - 1730.
Not only will we discover what’s become
of the many people involved, we learn about
what happened in the last moments before the
neutralization took place.
And perhaps most importantly of all, for the
sake of our universe, we will find out how
Site 13 came into existence - and how Site
Director Emerson went down such a dark path.
It’s time to get some answers.
Welcome to the final part of the SCP - 1730
Saga, as we close the book on one of the most
deadly locations in the Foundation multiverse.
First to sit down in the interview chair was
Captain Ephram Ross, leader of Mobile Task
Force Apollo 3 also known as The Game Wardens.
He was a shaken man, looking far older than
his 35 years, his eyes heavy with the weight
of the horrors he’d seen.
He and his team were among the first to venture
into the bowels of Site 13 and witness the
atrocities that’d gone on down there like
the Body Pit, full of fleshy slurry, or the
countless containment chambers that marked
their occupants for vivisection and termination.
Captain Ross was haunted by the things that
had happened to his team under his watch such
as the anomalous transformation of Houston’s
legs and the nightmarish warping death of
Noah at the hands of a stretchy, reality-bending
anomaly.
He compared the state of chaos going on down
there to something like Jurassic Park, where
all hell had broken loose and the monsters
ruled.
He also remarked on the Olympia Containment
Cells, each the size of a football stadium,
capable of containing things far beyond the
scope of this universe’s SCP Foundation.
His interviewer was the hard-nosed Dr. Peter
Vincent, who thanked Captain Ross for his
contributions, and called in the next interview
subject: Agent Liam Ohalo, a Game Wardens
Task Force member working under Captain Ross.
He had a thousand yard stare, and even the
untrained observer could see that Agent Ohalo
had left some part of himself back in Site
13.
When Dr. Vincent attempted to interview him,
he mostly remained silent, only volunteering
one grim sentiment:
“We should’ve died in there.
This isn’t real.
We were supposed to die in there.”
Next to be interviewed was Captain Irantu
of Mobile Task Force Tau-5, aka Samsara.
His interviewer, Dr. Isha Saint Claire, questioned
him about the nature of the mission, and the
cybernetic soldier was even-keeled about the
matter.
He said that, in spite of regrettable losses
of life, he was still satisfied with the outcome
of the mission overall.
The high-value targets were rescued, the anomaly
was - for all intents and purposes - neutralized,
and the degree of loss was actually better
than their pre-mission predictions.
It seems that the weight of death doesn’t
weigh quite as heavily on those who will probably
never have to experience it, as the Samsara
team are capable of simply being rebooted
into new bodies if terminated in the field.
People like Captain Hollis weren’t as lucky.
Next, Agent Cotter Houston of the Game Wardens
was both interviewed and medically evaluated
by Dr. Ian Harris.
Agent Houston had his legs dematerialized
after he tripped into a rising tide of anomalous
liquids - which he described as looking like
a moving, physical computer glitch.
However, in spite of this, Agent Houston is
still able to stand and move of his own free
will.
It seemed to Dr. Harris that Houston’s legs
were somehow trapped between dimensions.
Houston told Dr. Harris that he didn’t experience
any kind of pain when his legs were removed,
but to this day, he occasionally feels something
furry brushing up against them.
Perhaps, wherever his legs are, they aren’t
alone...
Next, the stoic Agent Munru of Samsara was
interviewed by Captain Elliott O’Neil of
Mobile Task Force D-26, also known as Time
Cops.
Captain O’Neil had a bone to pick with Munru
- namely, that he’d allowed Captain Hollis
to run off and sacrifice her own life, despite
having a clear directive to prevent the human
task force members from endangering themselves
at any cost.
Munru deflected, claiming that when Hollis
separated from the group, he assumed that
she ran off with intentions that never included
her own demise.
O’Neil and the Foundation found this answer
unsatisfying, and decided to move on to their
next interview with Onru - the last person
with Captain Hollis before her death.
The interviewer, Dr. Darian Arnold, probed
the elite Samsara operative on why she turned
off her camera before she and Hollis reached
the Thresher - the machine that Hollis overloaded
to annihilate Site 13 from our dimension.
She gave a more compelling answer than Munru:
When she and Hollis entered a server room
on the way to the Thresher, they encountered
what may have been the ultimate cognitohazard:
It was a vision of a terrifying alternate
dimension with billions dead.
A poisoned star like the biblical wormwood
fell from the burning sky.
A Nightmare God, like the one torturing Elliot
Emerson, wandered among fields of crucified
people, covered in deadly, cognitohazardous
runes.
Just looking at it burned the SCRAMBLE technology
out of Munru’s eyes, and she turned off
her cameras to avoid potentially frying the
brains of mission control.
Hollis wasn’t so lucky.
The things she witnessed broke her sanity,
and when she finally overloaded the Thresher
machine, she was laughing and crying.
Finally, in perhaps the most enlightening
debriefing interview of them all, Site Director
Willam Vesterland interviewed Dr. Mohammed
Scott - The highest-ranking researcher of
Site 13, and confidant of the now-infamous
Director Elliot Emerson.
The question was simple: just what had happened
for Site 13 to become so messed up?
And Dr. Scott answered in detail, with a tale
of corruption, alternate realities, and the
perils of unchecked power.
In his home dimension, Site 13 was originally
created in Nome, Alaska to house the corpse
of a giant sea creature that beached itself
on the border of India and Bangladesh in 1964.
It became the largest and most secretive Foundation
containment facility in the latter half of
the 20th century.
However, disaster struck in 1994, when a Marxist
extremist used an anomaly to level the Willis
Tower in Chicago.
As a result, the Foundation lost a lot of
its funding and international support, leaving
it in dire financial straits.
Enter the true villain of the Site 13 story:
Paul Manafort.
If that name sounds familiar to you, it’s
because he was an associate of President Trump
in our universe who got into legal trouble
for shady international dealings.
However, in Dr. Scott’s universe, he was
a powerful staffer for President Bob Dole
- who in that reality had beaten Bill Clinton
in the 1996 Presidential Election.
Manafort was made the new Secretary General
of the Global Occult Coalition - The UN’s
answer to the SCP Foundation, and one of their
leading competitors, with an ethos geared
towards killing rather than containing anomalies.
Manafort and the GOC co-opted the struggling
Foundation, providing them with money in exchange
for control.
The Foundation had no choice but to accept
this deal with the devil.
Slowly, Manafort replaced the Foundation old
guard with toadies and loyalists.
The Ethics Committee and the O5 command were
dismantled.
Dissenters were dragged out of their offices
and shot point blank in the head, execution-style.
Site 13 had originally been directed by Dr.
Bright, but Bright was arrested and contained
under false pretences so Manafort could install
a new director: A mid-level researcher by
the name of Elliot Emerson.
Emerson is often painted as a sadistic monster
who took pleasure in torturing anomalies to
death and flushing them down the body pit.
The reality is both simpler and more grim:
Emerson, it turns out, was just an eager yes
man.
He was put into his position to follow Manafort’s
orders to a tee, and those orders were simple
- Kill.
In a perfect example of the banality of evil,
Director Emerson converted Site 13 into a
brutal slaughterhouse, just as his overlords
at the GOC had ordered him.
But things were quickly getting out of hand,
and one of the most vocal critics of the new
regime was one of Emerson’s old lovers,
one Dr. Vera Hadley, Assistant Director of
Anomalous Biology.
Dr. Hadley was disgusted by the inhuman acts
Emerson was carrying out and couldn’t stay
silent, and for this she faced horrific consequences.
Corrupt guards stripped her and beat her to
within an inch of her life in front of her
co-workers.
In that moment, she swore her revenge.
She sabotaged the containment procedures and
had the engineers rig the already unstable
Thresher device to overload.
As Emerson watched the anomalies break containment
he began to fear for his life - both from
the anomalies themselves, and from the punishments
of his superiors at the GOC.
Dr. Scott revealed that Emerson was no evil
mastermind.
He was a lapdog for the GOC.
A dirty coward, all the way to the very end.
And he was desperate.
He held Dr. Scott at gunpoint and ordered
him to activate the Thresher or die, and the
rest is history.
There would be no redemption for Dr. Scott’s
former friend, as Emerson ended up chained
to the rune-covered, platform head of a Nightmare
God for all eternity.
So ends the debriefing of the Site 13 survivors,
and closes the book on that terrible place
- for now, anyway.
The story of SCP - 1730 is anything but simple,
and there are so many angles from which this
dark tragedy of cruelty and corruption can
be approached.
And ultimately, it was all for the same two
things at the root of every evil: The desire
for money and power.
But the pursuit of these base desires can
lead to some truly nightmarish consequences,
and nobody knows this better than former Director
Elliot Emerson - who’ll be paying for these
sins until the end of time, and perhaps even
beyond.
Now go check out another epic tale from the
SCP Foundation, SCP-5000 - The Suit.